merci
comme plus d'un million de musulmans au
canada la famille de zones à b achraf
célèbre aujourd'hui la fin du ramadan
enfin parents et enfin peuvent célébrer
ensemble
après deux mois de confinement c'était
dur c'était un mois vraiment dur parce
que pour nous le ramadan c'est le
rassemblement c'est la famille c'est
c'la c'est l'amour c'est la joie c'est
tout puis avec le confinement je me suis
trouvée genre loin de ma famille loin
même avec la distanciation sociale ça
fait du bien de
de les voir qu'ils essaient santé de la
peine de ne pas embrasser ne met bientôt
j'espère bientôt riche dans ce parc de
montréal les scènes de la vie courante
se multiplient les activités sont
nombreuses tout comme les sourires
aujourd'hui on est vraiment très très
heureux de se rassembler mais on garde
toujours la distance ça c'est sûr avec
le désinfectant aussi on se lave les
mains il faut toujours rester conscient
c'est le plus important en étant
responsable donc on essaie de garder de
m je pense que les gens en général ils
respectent tous les décisions que le
gouvernement a mis y est donc
mais le respect des consignes ne fait
pas l'unanimité à gatineau
la présence policière sera augmentée
pour faire respecter les règles
situation similaire à toronto
le parc trinity berguoise attiré des
milliers de personnes samedi soir la
police a dû intervenir
la ville a vivement critiqué la
situation à montréal aussi la présence
policière se fait sentir
l'objectif est de sensibiliser les gens
vis-à-vis les risques de propagation du
virus cet ennemi invisible bien présent
dans la communauté ici marie michel
lauzon radio-canada à montréal